I miss I miss being a kid I miss the
carefree days I miss waking up in the
morning and spelling my mom's turkey saw
in eggs that's definitely what I miss
most though he's so nice waking up to
that smells
reminds me a home it's being home it's
probably been out here for a while now
shipping out so I miss home well next to
my family as my wife is just indicated
probably my dogs I've had dogs my whole
life and the things you get attached to
when you say goodbye it's a tough thing
to do particularly because normally
you're there with them I miss the small
things I used to play in a band
we wouldn't famous or anything but we
had a lot of fun and having that back in
my life wouldn't be so tragic so what do
I miss my mom yes what'd I miss cuz I'm
really happy with my life and my family
and everything in it and my mom was so
part of it it'd be really cool so it's
kind of simple quite a simple answer but
I think a lot of people can relate to
that I feel like at a point in my life
I'm really tied down I'm in the middle
of nursing school and I feel like I
sometimes hardly have a moment to
breathe what I miss most is traveling
and not really knowing what I'm going to
do next
and not really wanting to play in what I
do next
hmm the thing I miss most in life up to
today is actually flying together with
my wife hiker as a passenger in a safe
place yeah we're playing pilots but
actually we have planned to go to Lake
Elsinore soaring Club and go flying over
there
[Music]
actually I just lost my robot that I had
for eight years
you got fancy and that's what I miss
most Hey
freedom total freedom maybe like you get
everywhere you go always got
restrictions and stuff and never can be
really free life like you have to pay
taxes and stuff [ __ ] like that and I
don't know I think yeah that's one thing
I miss the most enlightening childhood
friends people I grew up with in middle
school
everyone will do it
communication seems like people don't
communicate enough these days you have
to guess what they got or you know you
just don't get enough information
anymore from people
electronical games electronic games
things like that it's just people don't
feel like they don't want to talk or
they don't want to they want to text you
or they wanna you know FaceTime you
instead of coming face-to-face
unlike personal person
childlike sense of wonder thank you
explain nothing now everything's more
rules and regulations like I'm in the
military so like we look at things from
a logical point of view instead of
looking at things with more imagination
police say my grandma and grandpa both
of them passed away recently so yeah
probably them well I miss my people back
in Africa particularly might be afferent
people people who have been acting for
their own country they have been
innocently been acting for freedom
growing up with my family
Polly used to have a lot more time
together and now we're all grown up and
going our own directions so kind of just
seems like maybe part of you is missing
having fun I work too much and that's
the truth probably running track and
field but why I miss most in life or
sunsets what my little brother smells
for my childhood I like my grandma's
baking some dinner
some meat dish and it smells really good
I miss my family and my best friends
from back in the country I haven't seen
them for a few years now so I really
miss them I want to go back home and
visit them no I'm like pretty content
moving forward in life I don't know why
it is certain things because I feel like
while losing some things that were like
seem positive the iosef gained more
perspective like for it was like the
innocence of childhood is like a
wonderful thing
at the same time getting a lot of
knowledge and like maturing growing
abroad a lot of joy
so let's say I'm just looking for not
stability
has to be one word no no I can explain
there you could leave it at that I might
leave it at that okay what's your name
Wayne and where you from
Anton and what do you miss most in life
memories that I don't remember it
[Music]
[Music]
you